Гроші на вугіллі -
чорні скарби Австралії
Масштабні руйнування -
день після торнадо
Перед виборами - після виборів -
Штефан Вайль - лідер партії FDP в Нижній Саксонії
В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман та Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Добрий вечір!
Ми розпочинаємо випуск з найбільшої у світі
країни-експортера вугілля.
Ця країна - на іншому кінці Землі,
однак все, що там відбувається
має вплив і на нас.
Ми усі живемо на одній планеті
і маємо лише її єдину.
Люди в Австралії проголосували за зміну влади.
Прем'єрміністр Скотт Моррісон -
суперечлива фігура через жорстку позицію
щодо коронавірусу і до мігрантів,
«бульдозер», як він сам себе називав,
також відомий як прихильник вугільного лобі -
втратив свою посаду.
А цей чоловік - виграв вибори.
Ентоні Альбаніз, відомий як Альбо.
Вперше за майже десятиліття в Австралії -
соціал-демократичний уряд.
Новий прем'єр описує себе як захисник клімату.
Водночас є дещо, що хвилює жителів не лише Австралії -
Альбо керуватиме країною,
в якій вугілля має такий високий попит як ніколи.
«Вбивця клімату», який зараз приносить великі гроші.
З Австралії - Нормен Оденталь.
Долина Хантер, Новий Південний Уельс,
демонструє ідеальний австралійський пейзаж.
Саме тут Марго і Майкл Вайт пасуть свою худобу.
Ферма – це їхнє життя.
Але все висить на волосинці.
У двох кроках від їхніх лугів
світ незабаром стане іншим.
На цьому місці вже працюють екскаватори.
«В цьому регіоні вони зможуть видобути
50 млн тонн вугілля
в період між 2023 та 2029 роками.
Юридично у нас немає жодних шансів,
всі дозволи вже видані.
Як кажуть в Австралії, ми - «застрелені качки».
Це - майбутнє.
Планета «Вугілля».
Регіон вже нагадує кратер.
І з'являються все нові і нові шахти.
Жодної мови про скорочення,
лише про збільшення,
тому що чорний скарб Австралії імпортують
від Китаю до Індії
і постійно з'являються нові покупці.
Ця галузь приносить дохід
та задовольняє економіку.
«Мені здається, що багатьом державам
з огляду на останні події в Європі, в Україні
доведеться переглянути свій енергетичний курс.
І це, безумовно, включає подальше
використання вугілля».
Якщо ви не хочете імпортувати енергію з Росії,
вам потрібні інші постачальники.
Австралія зі своєю вугільною промисловістю
отримує зиск від актуальної кризи.
Також і робітники цієї галузі.
У середньому їхній заробіток становить
80-90 тис. євро на рік
і, здається, що робочі місця гарантовані.
У сільському пабі відчувається
впевненість у завтрашньому дні.
У нас достатньо запасів вугілля.
Через кризу, спричинену війною в Україні,
попит величезний.
І завтра криза не закінчиться.
Наше вугілля просто необхідне
і воно - найкращої якості.
Від вугілля багато залежить:
велика кількість робочих місць на шахтах,
з постачальниками - увесь ланцюжок.
Якщо ми відмовимось від вугілля, що тоді?
Австралія хоче досягти кліматичної нейтральності
до 2050 року, пізніше за інших,
але все ж хоче.
Вугілля – найбільша перешкода, яку постійно критикують,
звинувачують у зміні клімату.
У Австралії гостро відчувають наслідки зміни клімату:
повені, лісові пожежі, посухи.
Але відмова від вугілля відтермінована
на довший час, ніж будь-коли раніше.
Керівні партії ухиляються від конкретних зобов'язань.
Фермер Майкл розчарований.
«Не можна просто сказати:
допоки буде попит, доти ми продовжимо
видобувати вугілля.
У такому випадку Австралія
не дотримається своєї глобальної відповідальності.
А я як дідусь 6 онуків
не дотримаюся своєї відповідальності»
Зеленою або сірою:
якою буде Долина Хантер завтра?
Вугілля приносить достаток і руйнує ідилію.
Досить важко одночасно
прагнути першого і зберегти друге.
Три торнадо у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії.
Один торнадо вдарив у центр Падерборна.
Це було лише кілька хвилин,
але подібного у нас ніколи не бачили
і не хотіли б бачити.
Багато місць в Німеччині
зазнали пошкоджень через торнадо.
Наймасштабніші руйнування -
на Сході Північного Рейну-Вестфалії.
День після торнадо означає велике прибирання.
І для багатьох лише зараз зрозуміло, що сталося.
Тадеус Параде розповість детальніше.
Звук бензопил -
саме його можна почути скрізь у суботу в Падерборні.
Прибирання наслідків лиха наступного дня.
«Зачистити» хаос, оцінити заподіяну шкоду.
Люди все ще не можуть оговтатися від стихії,
яка тривала декілька хвилин.
Це сила, яку ви навіть не можете собі уявити.
Дерева на узбіччі дороги. Я дивився у вікно:
їх виривало з корінням, наче вони легкі як сірники.
Як повідомляє Метеорологічна служба Німеччини,
три торнадо лютувало вчора.
І це лише на Сході Вестфалії.
Руйнівна сила дивує багатьох.
На парковці біля Центру тестування на коронавірус
сидячи в автомобілі люди хвилювались за своє життя.
Дивує руйнівна сила, яка відірвала верхівку шпиля церкви.
Сила, яка ламала дерева як сірники.
На думку метеорологів,
таким екстремальним погоднім явищам
сприяє зміна клімату.
Потрібно сказати, що через зміну клімату
таких екстремальних кліматичних явищ побільшає.
За таких екстремальних негод
зростає ймовірність сильних торнадо.
Втім, не кожна негода несе в собі загрозу торнадо.
Наприклад, під час грози, яка очікується у понеділок,
ймовірність торнадо дуже низька.
43 особи поранені та мільйони збитків.
Потрібні тижні, місяці, щоб усунути всі пошкодження.
Але непевність залишиться,
оскільки такого лихо в Падерборні ще не було.
На вихідних погода має бути спокійною,
але з понеділка знову очікуються грози.
Стара приказка каже:
«Перед виборами - після виборів».
Вона, як і усі старі політичні вислови,
звичайно, правдива.
Останні вибори у двох землях
були невдалими для SPD,
на наступних виборах хмари нависнуть
над прем'єрміністром партії.
Хоча до голосування в Нижній Саксонії
залишилося кілька місяців,
колишній почесний громадянин Ганноверу
Герхард Шредер вже приносить проблеми
власній партії SPD у своїй рідній федеральній землі.
Канцлер Німеччини сьогодні відвідав Нижню Саксонію
і своїх колег з партії, які готуються до виборів.
Пітер Кунц детальніше.
Штормові вихідні в Німеччині
і не підвладний штормам Олаф Шольц з відвідинами.
«Штормостійкі», так себе називають нижньосаксонці.
Один із них - Олаф Шольц:
народився тут, похрещений вже в Гамбурзі.
Шольц приносить попутний вітер з Берліну
для Штефана Вайля,
який наступним братиме участь від SPD
на виборах до земельного парламенту.
Дві попередні поразки на виборах та низькі рейтинги опитувань
хвилюють канцлера:
Цього року вибори відбувалися тричі.
В одному випадку нам вдалося
з другого місця вийти на перше.
Для зміни уряду на двох інших виборах
нам не вистачило розмаху,
але це лише підґрунтя для того,
щоб ми зробили те, що потрібно зараз.
Необхідно скинути баласт.
Підлеглий Путіна та нижньосаксонець Герхард Шредер
більше не має заважати цим двом «штормостійким».
Я, як і, до речі, Штефан Вайль, давно казав,
що Герхард Шредер повинен піти з цієї посади,
і ми очікуємо, що він так і зробить,
а  незабаром це торкнеться й інших.
Герхард Шредер нині виступає виключно за себе.
Для партії SPD у Нижній Саксонії Олаф Шольц
раніше не був кандидатом-улюбленцем,
але зараз, коли він обіймає посаду канцлера,
з ним значно зблизились.
Я думаю, що він не завжди вдало комунікує,
але я повністю підтримую те, що він робить.
Деякі люди надають перевагу політикам-балакунам,
а інші цінують врівноважену подачу інформації,
врівноважену політику
і це, безумовно, те, що властиве Олафу Шольцу.
Я абсолютно переконаний, що спокій, розсудливість,
час на роздуми та обміркування - це те,
що нині потрібно
переважній більшості людей у Німеччині.
Олафе, ти не один.
Принцип Шольца - залишатися непохитним.
Сьогодні мешканцям Нижньої Саксонії
канцлер, якого часто звинувачують
у недостатньому роз'ясненні,
пояснив, що він має на увазі
під стійкістю під час бурі,
коли одну бурю змінює інша.
Пандемія, Україна, невдоволеність населення через інфляцію.
У п'ятницю у Бундестазі і Федеральній раді
ми завершили роботу
над законопроєктом щодо надання
30-мільярдного пакета допомоги.
Одноразові виплати допоможуть тим,
у кого мало грошей.
Задоволення партійних мас керівництвом
вже давно рідкість в партії SPD.
Але партію також застав період змін.
Тепер усі підтримують канцлера.
Шольц і Вайль на одному плакаті,
але на виборах у Нижній Саксонії 9 жовтня
з'явиться лише один.
Хтось опікується питаннями на рівні країни,
а хтось - питаннями на рівні земель.
Щасливої дороги! Час відпочити
після робочого тижня.
Партія Лівих також зайнята аналізом
результатів на виборах.
Проте цього разу йдеться про принципові питання.
Ханно, тобі слово.
У розпал кризи очільниця партії Лівих
Жанін Віслер оголосила,
що знову балотуватиметься на цю посаду.
Наприкінці червня на
федеральному партійному з'їзді партії Лівих
буде достроково обрано новий склад правління.
Віслер заявила, що своєю кандидатурою
вона хоче сприяти відродженню Лівих.
Партія перебуває під сильним тиском
після поразок на останніх трьох земельних виборах
та звинувачень у сексизмі.
Для вирішення конфлікту щодо вступу до НАТО
Фінляндії та Швеції
президент Туреччини Реджеп Ердоган
провів телефонні розмови з лідерами обох країн.
За повідомленнями, Ердоган закликав Швецію
відмовитися від підтримки терористичних груп,
зокрема Робітничої партії Курдистану PKK,
а також скасувати
ембарго на експорт зброї до Туреччини.
Прем'єрміністерка Швеції Магдалена Андерссон
після телефонної розмови заявила,
що підтримує боротьбу з тероризмом.
Президент Фінляндії Саулі Нійністе
написав у Twitter про «відверту розмову».
У середу обидві країни подали
заявки на вступ до НАТО.
Туреччина наразі не підтримує вступ країн до НАТО.
Запланована на сьогодні в Ірані
страта ірано-шведського вченого
Ахмада Рези Джалалі,
очевидно, не відбулася.
Як повідомила «heute journal»
дружина Джалалі Віда Меранніа
Міністерство юстиції Ірану
розгляне питання про відстрочку виконання вироку.
Вона також звернулася до ЄС
із закликом діяти та врятувати її чоловіка.
2017 року Джалалі засудили в Ірані до страти
за звинуваченням у шпигунстві.
Комітет ООН з прав людини
назвав загрозу страти «свавіллям».
Ще 2 випадки захворювання мавпячою віспою
було виявлено в Німеччині, а саме у Берліні.
За даними Головного управління з питань охорони здоров'я,
стан хворих стабільний.
Тільки вчора стало відомо
про перший випадок захворювання в Мюнхені.
Пацієнт у Мюнхені хворий
на західноафриканський варіант вірусу
з легшим перебігом.
Інститут Роберта Коха заявляє
про ймовірність нових випадків захворювання в Німеччині,
але це на буде хвиля інфекцій.
На черзі лотерея.
Номери лотереї на екрані.
Всі дані, як завжди, без гарантій.
А зараз прогноз погоди.
На північному сході та південному заході
завтра подекуди пройдуть короткочасні дощі.
В інших регіонах очікується сонячна погода
з мінливою хмарністю.
Максимальна температура 16° на Рюгені,
26° на Верхньому Рейні.
У понеділок від 20° до 27° на північному сході,
на заході та півдні очікуються
сильні грози, зливи, град і шквали.
У вівторок і середу погода буде мінливою
та прохолоднішою.
Сьогоднішні ми також поговоримо
про 2 футбольні команди,
у яких сьогодні ввечері є шанс
досягти найбільшого тріумфу в історії своїх клубів.
Не обидві, звісно, мають шанс, а лише одна.
Фінал Кубку Німеччини з футболу:
«Фрайбург» проти «РБ Лейпциг».
Одна з команд - місцеві прості хлопці
із сонячного південного заходу Німеччини,
іншу деякі досі вважають спортивною компанією,
а не футбольним клубом.
Рахунок 1:1 на кінець основного часу,
потім овертайм,
а потім серія пенальті.
А зараз про це детальніше Фолькер Грубе.
Заповнений Олімпійський стадіон у Берліні
і щирі побажання від Йоахіма Лева,
колишнього тренера збірної Німеччини
тренеру Крістіану Штрайху команди «Фрайбург».
Його команда грає дуже рішуче від початку.
19 хвилина. Гюнтер, Шаллаї, Еггештайнвільний,
і - перший гол.
Рахунок 1:0.
Ідеальний удар з 18 метрів.
«Фрайбург» тепер веде.
Шаллаї торкнувся рукою м'яча неумисно,
тому гол зараховують.
«РБ Лейпциг» чинить опір і посилює атаку.
Промах «Фрайбурга». Хьофлердає пас назад.
Невдача. Нкунку з м'ячем.
Шлоттербекне дає «Лейпцигу» зрівняти рахунок.
Команда Тедесковиходить після перерви
з жагою до перемоги.
Але «Фрайбург» контратакує.
Хьолер, за ним Гальстенберґ,
який не знаходить іншого способу зупинити противника,
крім навмисного поштовху.
Це, без сумнівів, червона картка.
«Фрайбург» намагається втримати невелику перевагу.
«РБ Лейпциг» не здається.
Із мужністю та відчаєм біжать десять саксонців,
і після попередньої невдачі Нкунку
зрівнює рахунок на 76 хвилині.
З ідеальною реакцією та тактичністю.
Навіть на 120 хвилині матчу немає переможця.
Серія пенальті.
Після захисника «Фрайбурга» Крістіана Гюнтера
не забиває й Ермедін Демирович.
«Лейпциг» уперше у своїй історії виграє
Кубок Німеччини з футболу
після двох поразок у минулих фіналах турніру.
У Саксонії сьогодні святкуватимуть всю ніч.
О 00:45 в ефірі «heute Xpress»
із Ральфом Шепанським.
Завтра ми з радістю зустрінемось з Вами
у цій студії.
Гарного вечора!